in the news of you know the news doesn't
wait on anyone the u.s. abstained from
vetoing a UN Security Council resolution
condemning Israeli settlements I want to
bring the language up on the screen if
you don't mind Pat so we could see
specifically what was said the
resolution said it it's condemning all
measures aimed at altering the
demographic composition character and
status of the Palestinians territory
occupied since 1967 including East
Jerusalem including the construction and
expansion of settlements transfer of
Israeli settler settlers confiscation of
land demolition of homes and
displacement of Palestinian civilians in
violation of international humanitarian
law and relevant resolutions so this is
the language and it is set off a
firestorm and even though the language
comes off as brash and I'll just use
that word you could take it however you
need to take it it is a resolution that
really had no teeth and in terms of
doing something it's just a condemnation
of the settlements but you would have
thought that this was the u.s. I mean
well anyway I'll leave all hyperbolic
language for my show later on let's play
let's pull up the statement from
Samantha power who was the US ambassador
to the security to the UN she said today
the Security Council reaffirmed its
established consensus that settlements
have no legal validity President Obama
and Secretary Kerry have repeatedly
warned publicly and privately the that
the absence of progress towards peace
and continued settlement expansion was
going to put the two-state solution at
risk and threaten Israel's stated
objective to remain both a Jewish and
Jewish state and a democracy this
resolution reflects trends that will
permanently destroy the hope of a
two-state solution if they continue on
their current course all right so that's
one thing that she stated I found it
very interesting how the UN Ambassador
positioned the u.s. is sentiment and you
can see it best demonstrated in this
clip
it is because this form too often
continues to be biased against Israel
because there are important issues that
are not sufficiently addressed in this
resolution and because the United States
does not agree with every word in this
text that the United States did not vote
in favor of the resolution but it is
because this resolution reflects the
facts on the ground and is consistent
with US policy across Republican and
Democratic administrations throughout
the history of the State of Israel that
the United States did not veto it okay
so it's interesting positioning there
right so the first position is that that
this resolution does not address all of
the issues that concerns Israel right so
the first half of a statement was very
sympathetic towards Israel and that this
this committee this the the UN Security
Council has been unfair to Israel you
know she's using language trying to
position herself on the side of Israel
as the reason why they didn't vote for
the resolution yeah it's a very calm
diplomatic language we could see she's
not trying to burn any bridges here with
Rio or with Netanyahu yeah but it you
know it didn't really matter because the
second half of her statement burned all
the bridges in the world was she
essentially said that this reflects the
reality on the ground it reflects the
position of both American both
Democratic and Republican
administrations it's pretty par for the
course for many of America merica
positions on Israel that's why they did
not be to it but in essence not be
toeing it it's still tacit support for
it and this is what Netanyahu of course
we have on the screen this is what he's
come out and full you know he's taken
this as a full affront to the us-israeli
relationship and if you read this on the
screen next he said according to our
information we have no doubt that the
Obama administration initiated it the
resolution stood behind it
coordinated the wording and demanded it
be passed
he also said friends don't take friends
to the Security Council I thought that
was both telling and hilarious for for
many many reasons it is on record that
Egypt in fact initially
created the the resolution however
Netanyahu rejects this now I'm not I'm
not dismissing the possibility that
America could have had Egypt to put this
resolution in I get that but as far as
what's on the record its Egypt's
resolution and yet he's taking it out on
America because America didn't veto it
yeah Netanyahu is getting quite ahead of
himself here I mean this is the first
time that a vote in the UN that the US
has taken a position on it can even be
perceived at all as anti-israel and we
recently just approved a aid package the
largest in the two nation's history of
38 million dollars third billion Billy
yes 38 billion dollars which is
according to I forgot where Adam Johnson
is from Adam Johnson on Twitter I think
he's with salon which is more than the
aid we send seven countries seven
predominantly Muslim countries that were
bombing including Somalia and Yemen so
we were sinning a tremendous amount of
aid to Israel yet this is a complete
condemnation of America by Benjamin
Netanyahu such to the point where he's
recalled his ambassador to Israel the US
ambassador to Israel he has recalled
many other ambassadors related to this
but his language his language
specifically with regard to the outgoing
Obama administration and his full
embrace of the Trump administration
shows you that he's trying to play on
the this the steady divide there's
always in the United States you know
America that it's ironic that Republican
administrations and Democratic
administrations have hell consistent
positions in terms of policy on Israel
and the two-state solutions but Benjamin
Netanyahu feels like Donald Trump is
going to be a friend to Israel more so
than the Democratic administration
that's leaving you could see on the
screen here a tweet from Donald Trump as
the UN I switch back to that real quick
all as to the UN things will be
different after January 20th but here's
a statement that more in depth with
regard to the UN resolution he said the
resolution being considered at the
United Nations Security Council
regarding Israel should be vetoed this
was back on the 22nd of December he went
on to say as the
United States has long maintained peace
between the Israelis and the
Palestinians will only come through
direct negotiations between the parties
and not through the imposition of terms
by the United Nations this was Israel in
a very poor negotiating position and an
extremely unfair to all Israelis my only
question here Pat is you know the UN
giveth and the UN taketh away I mean
there's a lot that the UN has done in
favor of Israel so now all of a sudden
is the UN the enemy of Israel according
to Donald Trump I I'm not really sure
how to read that statement from them or
even if we should try to analyze it we
probably shouldn't know I think he's
just trying to take both sides yet again
yeah yeah there's no reason to analyze
this statement from Trump other than the
fact that he is the president-elect and
so his statements like this have a lot
of impact